die frage dann können sie ja bitte
nochmal antrag auf jeden tag herr
minister schlappe können den sachverhalt
abkürzen ist interessiert mich auch
nicht was sie sonst besprochen haben sie
bestätigen es gab das gespräch in großer
runde am 22
das spiegelt auch lage war ja sie haben
nicht auf den vorwurf des inhaltes
gespräch stellen und deswegen noch mal
ganz konkret gab es das angebot der
betreiber den vertrag erst nach dem
urteil zu unterschreiben und wenn es das
gab warum haben sie es abgelehnt und zum
zweiten in dem gespräch am 19
haben sie herrn schulberg aufgefordert
diesen sachverhalt zu verschweigen ja
oder nein ich schaue jetzt haben sie
eine - war nicht thema in dem gespräch
haben 22 november das thema war dass wir
zügig in diesem jahr noch zum abschluss
kommen weil ich aufgeklärt habe dass es
darum geht gesetz umzusetzen auch die
vorgaben aus dem haushaltsjahr 2018
umzusetzen wie sie wissen dass im
übrigens auch nicht geheim sondern das
liegt alles offen in den dokumenten die
wir in 51 akten mit tausenden von seiten
dem parlament zur verfügung gestellt
haben und auch der öffentlichkeit alles
abrufbar im bmvg
die fragen wurden bereits mehrfach
gestellt also von daher gibt es da
keinen neuigkeitswert zum zweiten im
übrigen da sieht man die fehlerhafte
recherche es heißt das am 19 06
neben herrn schulenberg herr kapsch
gesessen ist der kapsch war bei diesem
treffen konnte dabei das ist schon sehr
bemerkenswert aber vielleicht ist ja das
storyboard für diese geschichte schon
vorher festgestanden
und auch die überschriften da werden
wohl meine antworten die ich im vorfeld
dieser berichterstattung gemacht haben
wohl keine abhilfe mehr geschaffen haben
vielen dank an minister dann kommt jetzt
der kollege gepa und für die zuschauer
die sich jetzt wundern warum wir noch
nicht in der aktuellen stunde sind der
verkehrsminister scheuer wurde in der
fragestunde heer zitiert weil die
abgeordneten gesagt haben sie wollen dem
minister noch fragen stellen zu den
maut- vorgehen das hier gab
darum haben wir jetzt in die nächste
frage von den grünen den schulberg / von
irgendeinem verantwortlichen bei eventim
angeboten worden nach dem urteil erst
den vertrag abzuschließen ja oder nein
und zweitens zu einem zweiten treffen
noch mal die frage völlig egal ob das
geheim normal oder wie roma
stattgefunden hat ob er kapstadt war
oder auch nicht ist haben sie dort herrn
schulenberg explizit oder implizit
aufgefordert über ein solches angebot
schweigend zu wahren was anderes zu
erzählen die geschichte irgendwie so
darzustellen dass sie in ihrer
storyboard passt also am 19 juni nachdem
die kündigungen herr zugegangen sind
habe ich extra norm 18 juni mit internen
externen juristischen beistand gefragt
ob es angemessen ist oder ob es normal
ist dass man sich nach einer kündigung
mit in so einer breite des auftrags mit
den auftragnehmern nochmal unterhält um
auch die das urteil noch mal auszuwerten
dann wurde mir empfohlen dass wir ein
gespräch führen und das habe ich dann
gemacht am 19 juni ich glaube das ist
auch ein stil den ich gerne pflegen
nämlich dass man sich auch dann trifft
und miteinander redet auch wenn man die
kündigung ausgesprochen hat das haben
wir gemacht es hat dazu von mir und von
meiner seite keine aufforderungen
gegeben sondern es wurde darüber geredet
über die kündigungsgründe und dann ist
man auseinander gegangen dass man an
dieser situation des mgh feststellt dass
das eigene urteil leider recht weit
reichendes und dass man im system nur
schwerlich was verändern kann
das war der inhalt der gespräche zum 22
november zum thema 2018 jahr oder nein
das war überhaupt ein thema es war das
strukturpolitische ein thema wie man
sich organisatorisch einbringt das war
meine bitte an die auftragnehmer unter
den strukturpolitischen aspekt stichwort
wo kommen die arbeitsplätze hin der
kontrolle dieser info der erhebung der
infrastrukturabgabe und auch der
kontrolle was für überlegungen hat das
unternehmen also rein technisch
denn historische themen vielen dank herr
minister bitte achten sie auf die
redezeit gastel als nächster und dann
frau kollegin klug hat vielen dank frau
präsidentin herr minister ich habe eine
sehr grundlegende frage sie haben sich
mit diesem vorhaben der maut in ein sehr
hohes risiko gestürzt
ohne die ganzen warnungen zu hören und
nach dem scheitern
verweigern sie die aufklärung und ich
möchte von ihnen ganz einfach wissen
werden sie in den nächsten wochen eine
aufklärungsarbeit leisten und uns damit
einen parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss ersparen oder
werden sie uns weiterhin nötigen einen
solchen einzurichten weil sie nicht
aufklären was da geschehen ist vergessen
was sie politisch beschließen für sich
persönlich und was die einzelnen
fraktionen hier im wohnhaus beschließen
das ist da habe ich keinen einfluss da
hintergrund ist wir haben über 50
aktenordner dick bepackt ihnen zur
verfügung gestellt wo alle dokumente
klar gelegt sind auch die von ihnen
angesprochene oder nicht leider nicht
angesprochene risikoanalyse wir haben
mit externen und internen beratern das
so aufgelegt und so intensiv besprochen
in hunderten von workshops und immer
wieder rückversicherung im bezüglich
risikomanagement bezüglich des ausgangs
des bgh-urteils sie waren ja der der
gesagt hat warum haben sie nicht auf die
meinung des generalanwalts gewartet die
meinung des generalanwalts die haben die
frage im verkehrsausschuss gestellt das
hat uns gar nichts gebracht bei der
generalanwalt uns auf alle unsere
anliegen recht gegeben hat dass die
eu-kommission hat sogar die
infrastrukturabgabe in der letzten
periode sowie sie dann beschlossen wurde
begrüßt dass das risikomanagement ist
immer gemacht worden
und ich habe ja auch immer gesagt
schauen sie auf die homepage des bmv
auch für alle bürger zugänglich dass
alle dokumente offen gelegt wurden die
rechtlich vertretbar sind
die länder und jetzt kommt die kollegin
klugheit und dann die frau lemke jeweils
eine minute
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister es geht noch mal um die runde
am 22 november
es war eine große runde wir haben
hinweise darauf dass diese runde auch
genau dort die diskussion stattgefunden
hat um eine mögliche verschiebung dieses
angebot lag vor wohl und sie haben das
ausgeschlagen diese hinweise haben wir
den würden wir dann auch in der wohnungs
und dem problem würden wir dann auch in
einem untersuchungsausschuss nachgehen
deswegen würde ich ihr jetzt nochmal
einmal fragen vor der deutschen
öffentlichkeit gab es am 22 november
dieses angebot die die verschiebung der
verträge und haben sie das ausgeschlagen
minister auch zum wiederholten mal wenn
sie nachfragen wird meine antwort nicht
anders sein
und wenn sie hinweise haben dann legen
sie die hinweise offen wer sagt das als
wären wir waren genau vier leute dabei
bei dem treffen am 22 november dann ist
nach einer gesicherten erkenntnis mal
der zuständige staatssekretärin ich
dabei hatte wohl nicht der der das
behauptet also legen sie das offen sagen
sie den namen dann kann ich darauf
eingehen aber ich werde bei meiner
antwort ja vorher gehenden fragen
hundertprozentig bleiben vielen dank an
minister nächste nach rückfrage kollegin
lempe steffi lemke sprecherin für
naturschutz politik der grünen fraktion
eine frage des kollegen logisch nicht
beantworten wollte gekonnt hätte er ja
so lange ist herr ferlemann hier
staatssekretär und authentischen oft
rede und antwort gestanden
und da werde ich da hellhörig wenn sie
deshalb hierher kommen müssen und
deshalb möchte ich bei der frage nach
haken und ich möchte nicht über daten
oder beteiligte an gespräche von ihnen
eine auskunft sondern ob die aussage das
event time ihn wann und wo und mit wem
auch immer jemals das angebot gemacht
hat erst nach dem ogh urteil zu
unterschreiben
ob diese aussage gelogen
bis dann als sie weinen die firma
eventim ja die wurde von vor allem einer
person herrn schulenberg repräsentiert
und die zwei treffen die wir hatten an
dieser stelle an teil meiner frage sind
auf keinen fall mit irgendeiner datums
diskussion einher gegangen sondern unser
ziel war in 2018
die beiden verträge zu fixieren aus dem
einfachen grund weil die gesetzgebung im
deutschen bundestag uns den auftrag gibt
und den die vorgaben des
haushaltsausschusses aus unserer sicht
zu 100 prozent zu erfüllen sind und ich
komme gerne ins hohe haus und steht rede
und antwort der kollege ferlemann war
bei den treffen nicht dabei zuständige
verwandte staatssekretär war dabei und
von daher ist das überhaupt keine
spielerischen das ist das angebot das
angebot also wenn sie ihnen sagen es ist
keine lüge dass dieses angebot auf dem
tisch lag existierte es habe ich noch
überhaupt nicht gesorgt drehen sie mir
doch das wort nicht im stadt ungefragt
dankeschön nächste und voraussichtlich
letzte frage rückfrage dr rottmann
das ist niemals im ganzen jahr 2018 ein
solches angebot der firma eventim an
zigarren sind sie selbst nicht auf die
idee gekommen einen solchen vorschlag zu
machen
minister jetzt wiederhole ist zum
hundertsten mal sie sind ja nicht so
stark in der verkehrspolitik verankert
aber es das hohe haus hat eine
infrastrukturabgabe beschlossen hier das
hohe haus eine gesetzgebung beschlossen
die ein ministerium exekutive umsetzen
muss der haushaltsausschuss hat uns die
mittel dazu gegeben dass wir das in 2018
an den start bringen ist die aufgabe
eines ministers das zu tun so und
der auftragnehmer hätte ja wiederholt
die möglichkeit gehabt wenn ihm der
zeitplan nicht gepasst hätte von genau
diesen zeitplan sich zu entfernen oder
anders gesagt zu den unterzeichnung
terminen nicht zu erscheinen
der ist aber erschienen also war es im
beiderseitigen einverständnis dass wir
beide verträge nämlich kontrolle und
erhebung in 2018 abschließen wenn das
nicht möglich gewesen wäre für den
auftragnehmer dann hätte er dies ja
nicht gemacht so und von daher war es
überhaupt kein thema vom zeitplan her
das war nie im vordergrund gestanden
sondern nur die organisatorische und
technische umsetzung des vorhabens das
wiederum von allen begrüßt wurde und
beschieden wurde positiv von der
bundesregierung vom bundestag vom
bundesrat im übrigen auch mit den
stimmen von den grünen und auch von
thüringen beispielsweise dann dem
bundespräsidenten dann dem der
europäischen kommission volle zustimmung
durch den generalanwalt und ja die
enttäuschung war dann dass er teilt es
uns in diese diskussion überhaupt bringt
nicht mehr und nicht weniger das muss
man zur vervollständigung des ganzen
sonst sagen
vielen herzlichen dank damit ist die
fragestunde beendet war und die
fragestunde hat ja diesmal etwas länger
gedauert weil die abgeordneten darauf
gestanden haben